some [ __ ] is forever you understand
miles some [ __ ] is just forever
like what like for instance you cheat on
your wife right
with her sister it's bad that [ __ ] ain't
temporary that [ __ ] ain't gonna go away
that's [ __ ] like a rash
you're gonna put some [ __ ] ointment
on that [ __ ] you'll get a bad
ass rash you put some ointment on that
[ __ ] ointment
you know yeah ointment sounds like that
[ __ ] gonna get
worse ointment sounds like it's gonna
feed the [ __ ] rash i don't know
why they even call it ointment
ointment you know what i mean ointment
just sounds like i'm gonna give
you even more of a rash that's what
ointment sounds like to me anyway
if you're chilling your wife with her
sister she ain't gonna forget about that
[ __ ]
miles anything related to a sister
is going to always remind her that she
cheated on her with her [ __ ] sister
you came and watched a a family show
like sister sister remember that [ __ ]
uh tia tamara and [ __ ] remember that
[ __ ] yeah tia and [ __ ] tamara
you can't watch that [ __ ] freely
or what you're gonna keep thinking about
is sister to sister
her sister slept with her [ __ ]
husband and you're gonna never get over
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] don't go away do you have
siblings i do i got brothers
see i got brothers you know is it the
same if
one of you cheated on the other ones
like you know spouse or something like
that would that end or
how would y'all handle that first of all
being another find out
and second of all if that [ __ ] did
happen to me
i will never forget about that [ __ ] i'll
never forget it it would never go away
i can't buy a [ __ ] large
family-sized ointment and think that
[ __ ] gonna go away
you know what maybe you the
[ __ ] rash
for fooling around with your brother's
sister you the rash
this should give you some ointment to
rub on your body that will allow
to cure you and relieve the stress
and the tension of life but people have
got
to internalize their own
ointment which is a metaphor
for fix the [ __ ] that's wrong in your
life
so you don't have to relive it over and
over again
every time sister to sister come on
[ __ ] tv when i'm two goddamn twin
girls